welcome back to the 8th ever episode of
the iced coffee our
how you doing Graham good how are you
doing doing so well and that's crazy
because it's our 8th ever episode so
we've been doing this for almost two
months now crazy how much money we made
so far in this two months all right so
we have made approximately 960 dollars
there we go yeah nice congratulations
yeah nine hundred and thirty-six dollars
nice yes it is yeah we're really excited
youse are up everything's going fine
fine and Dan I think these are down
actually user views only go okay these
are down from the last video so we need
something to boost it up right now
exactly a lot of people have been saying
that we should post clips on our main
channel what do you think about that I
have not discussed this with you yet I
say we I'm surprised we haven't it's
weird because I feel like you should
have a second channel like a clips
channel and then you have a main channel
where you post a long version like Joe
Rogan does it seems like every podcast
does that but any reason why we would be
posting is because our views go down a
lot during the middle of the week can
you can you just basically do the most
exciting 10 minutes and we'll get it
like 10 minutes in one second and just
post it on Wednesday maybe something
like that like midweek yeah yeah yeah
for the people who don't want to listen
to the full like hour and a half we'll
just get like the top ten minutes of
condense down like the most exciting
stuff yeah and just this jam packet I
just didn't want to blow up peoples and
notifications yeah we're like posting a
bunch but if it's just one in the mid
week I think that'd be fine yeah let us
know down below in the comment section
what you think of that yeah the top
comment of the like the thing people
wanted to see it was you go through my
finances that's fine and or home
organize yeah and so I think we should
you just bought a guitar amp - I bought
him like you did that before you maxed
out your Roth IRA I know I haven't done
that I can entice me you is you're gonna
do it I see miss you well the sake
guitar amp comes first I guess right
yeah well yeah yeah all right so I will
max it out so that will happen have my
word it's better to do it now than wait
yeah had you done this back in March
you'd be up like 40 percent of money
this is very true you
we could make that one of the podcasts
that we do just you and I all just react
to your finances okay yeah possibly next
episode okay and then as for the ring
for those of you guys who are interested
what you have to do is follow Graham and
follow me on instagram and then comment
on my first post Jack the man and that's
how you get guys can get the ring and I
will be double checking to make sure the
winner is following both Graham and I
okay plot twist it's going to be the DVD
the ring Oh exactly you should have told
them that you may be wondering why we
have three mics and that's because we
have a spectacular guest the one the
only girlfriend to drink so welcome
Maci hi glad to be here I feel like it
took me so long to learn to look into
the lens of a camera and now there's two
and I have no idea and my sister you're
looking at you the camera lens is like
yeah here's no just just look at me you
talking Jack let's do a little bit of an
introduction for you for those who do
not know Graham would you care to
introduce I feels weird to introduce you
want to introduce yourself so hi guys
for those of you who don't know me I am
formally known as Graham's girlfriend or
Savannah Smiles but my name is Maci and
I am on this podcast I live with Graham
and I am his live-in actress roommates
we're keeping this PG for parental
guidance so welcome welcome to our car I
want to know how you have done on
YouTube compared to how you thought you
would have done on YouTube so I posted
my first video on the first day of the
year so New Year's mm-hmm and so I was
expecting you know 365 puts me
at December 31st and so I thought like
oh you know maybe I'll get monetized
around like July August you know I'll
have 25,000 subscribers probably by the
end like that that's my goal and so now
I'm here and I've been monetized since
April and I just hit 20,000 subscribers
so way better than I thought in a long
run about way one thing I wanted to know
is have any of your colleagues or
friends from high school or college
reach out to you because you know funny
enough I do have a few friends from high
school who found my channel that was
kind of mind-blowing to me but I haven't
had anyone from work find it yet like
luckily cuz I just feel like that'd be
really awkward for it's like you're
cheating on them a little bit it does
feel like that a little bit and then you
know it just it feels weird it'd be like
oh here's like me doing my skincare like
my co-workers watching my skincare
routine I think I feel like it's just
not very professional the stuff I do
it's just more relaxed and I'm having
fun so I just feel so awkward to my
colleagues they're like my boss weird to
see it not like anything's wrong with it
but it's just like would be awkward
because I'm so unprofessional really
nice you have such a nice garden no idea
yeah they like watching my garden tours
or whatever it's like it feels like you
know then watching me like overalls
versus like my normal work attire just
doesn't I don't know but yeah you have
had a few people reach out and be like
oh my goodness I found your channel or
even my Instagram I found that like a
lot of the people that I knew from high
school are following you know the
unofficial GGA Instagram and I'm like
wow that is so crazy
mm-hmm no it is crazy and it's funny too
because a lot of like even family
friends that I have was like raised with
all of a sudden so reaching out they're
like oh you're doing YouTube but I'm
like how did you know how did you find
me what is your your long-term plan
where do you see yourself in five to ten
years so five years and I mean
ideally at this point I think I've done
35 YouTube videos Asia at this point
I've had a good chance to test it out
and see that I like it so I would
imagine in five years I would want to be
doing YouTube full-time and maybe just
have some other part-time jobs are like
sources of income because I definitely
don't want to be tied to an algorithm
for my whole income source it seems very
stressful but yeah that's where I see I
want to have a rental property too
during that time like something that can
at least if everything went away that it
could at least I can barely I could live
off of it even if it was just barely so
you were in the finance a lot even
before you met Graham yeah yeah that was
something that we really clicked about I
remember one night that Graham and I
first started talking I think we're up
to like two am talking about credit card
points and different credit cards he's
telling me about like these ones cuz my
parents were always very against any
with like the annual annual fees yeah I
almost said statement so I knew that was
wrong but the annual fees so then when
he started saying hey no like this is
how it pays for it back was like wow
like my mind is just blowing so I can
remember there's that we were talking on
Chris you knew my prince forum before
even went on a first date that's what
made him so interested in me you asked
that question right away I think so no
if you ask areas like indirectly be like
you know something about credit scores
and then it just came up in conversation
I don't think I asked directly like what
you what you created score I think it
just brought it up like it just offered
this information willingly I'm like by
the way my credit cards over 715 he's
like what you're that age your credit
score is that I'm like yeah yeah it's
not like the text like guess what I'm
wearing tonight yeah it's like guess
what my credit score is 750 and like oh
haha say no have you enjoyed living in
West LA
I prefer way more than where we were
living before because there's so much
more to do in West LA the nice away and
easily all you do is drive to westerly
well really it wasn't
East LA was mids it's called mid-city
okay mid-city alley East LA is like by
downtown so
yeah but mid-city that's a mid-city
yeah anyways it's just there there was
like nothing to do besides drive to
Target but anywhere you wanted to go you
had to drive to in here it just feels
like yeah you can go drive somewhere but
I can make it to a target without
hitting traffic I can make it to you
know bond through that traffic I can't
make it to tree to do so many more
Trader Joe's on the west side by the way
yeah I know so many more Trader Joe's so
mm-hmm
it just feels like I can get places
without hitting a whole bunch of traffic
which I love so close to the beach yeah
that's true yeah yes oh you've got to
say it we're close proximity to the
beach oh yeah Oh in case you guys didn't
know we are close proximity to the beach
the beach is in close proximity and I
can't oh it's good it's good for values
for property that is to be close
proximity to the beach yes so would you
consider yourself a frugal person I
wouldn't say I'm frugal to the point of
Graham I would say more of a value
shopper my spending has definitely
gotten a little like my old over the
last few months I think being cooped up
in quarantine I'm just it's it's a
problem I'm like oh I want to do a video
on this I want to do this I want to do a
video on this like I want to buy this
and do a video and I've had to kind of
scale it back or it's grim doesn't have
this I'm gonna find him this gram
doesn't have this I'm gonna buy him this
cramped it and it's like stupid in there
there's a lot of stuff I don't have I
still don't have stuff where I'm at the
grocery store and I'm setting an extra
six dollars in like we don't have mochi
at home and Graham and I need mochi out
and so I'm trying to get better I do
I'm the excuse I'd say I'm more frugal
than most but I'm not extremely either
okay I can definitely spend and enjoy on
myself but I can be totally happy I'm I
got in my lunch budget now down to four
dollars for three weeks of food
she doesn't tell you it's ramen though
that really what youíve been doing cup
noodle ramen Network every day to save
money it's that way I don't feel bad
about the mochi yeah she leaves that
part out I thought that you were not
happy when gram goes to McDonald's now I
know you're eating ramen well I'm not
that's because what is healthier for you
because grandma's saying he kept
complaining he wasn't eating healthy
enough and I kept hearing about the him
complaining and then he was going to
eating McDonald's I'm like well why are
you complaining to me about your diet if
you're the one doing this to yourself
cuz that was on 72 once every two to
three weeks
I don't eat McDonald's every single day
if you're eating ramen four days a week
at lunch that that's way worse than me
eating McDonald's two to three times I
complain about my diet because overall
it's been a lot of like to snack foods
that aren't good that's why his ice
creams are so good mochi yeah this
stuff's mean with mochi I feel like I
like the mochi versus an ice cream tub
for you because I can get you just to
eat one tiny little ball and be done
versus eating a whole you know a little
pint of ice cream you have to train him
oh my goodness yeah well I was raised
with ice cream my house so for me to
open up a plaintiff one and take like
two or three bites and then put it away
it's totally easy but but grandma like
he takes it yeah well he just went to
our cookies and cream and he takes out a
little Oreo chunks and leaves the cream
first
that's far do you really yeah would you
like it if Graham scaled back on his
frugality think very carefully about
your answer there I'm fine with him
doing whatever makes him happy if he
felt that he was being overly frugal to
a point where he's impeding on his
happiness then yes I would want him to
scale it back if he feels like he is
spending too much and it's making him
stressed then I would want him to scale
back it's just hold on I don't care
about his frugality at all I mean I
don't want to say it like I don't want
him to be frugal or whatever I just
wanted to do whatever is gonna make him
happy on that
so if him being less frugal would make
him happy I'm all for it and if him
being more frugal what's gonna make him
happy more frugal then we will eat the
ramen to get there every day from not
ramen that's good
yeah it's a good answer how do you since
totally off - how do you make your stock
decisions would you say that you get a
lot of information from people like
Graham and stuff like that and then you
act on it oh hello he just cleaned it
[Applause]
we have Queens is booty anyway
stocked so how do you make your stock
decision I just you know I decide if
it's a good day to buy depending on how
well Ramsay clean this that's the best
the best due diligence anyone could do
honestly it's just if his booty is
cleaned thoroughly by night it's a green
day yeah so I would say really I don't
really listen to what they're investing
in it's usually I see a news article
about something I'm like oh hey I wonder
if this company is publicly traded and
then I'll start looking at up and then
I'll and then that's how I usually find
whatever stock he's like I found neo and
it was that like five dollars it's not
like 14 now which I just sold out of
half of it you're rubbing your eyes over
the new continue we'll discuss that
later
continue so I saw something in there
about how the Chinese government was
bailing them out and had that how they
had all this funding coming in it's just
like ah that's that's interesting I'm
wondering if they're you know publicly
traded it was like one of the first few
articles I was coming out about that and
so I looked at it and I was looking at
their financials I'm like okay looks
like it has a good upwards trend and if
the Chinese government is bailing them
out because they're saying that they
think this is the future it's probably a
good buy and so obviously there's more I
looked at than just that simple logic
but that's kind of what I'm gonna boil
it down to but so that's kind of it's
usually that I see an article about
something like oh this company you know
something good in relation to a company
and then I kind of start looking though
or they publicly traded ok here's what
their stocks trading at okay here's the
financials okay here's where the company
is located okay here's here's the CEO
what does a CEO have like a weird past
you know did you sell out of you said
half of me oh and what price did you
sell out uh it was at 14 today so I sold
it out at 14 I wanted to
I sold half of it today I want to make
sure since its trendy soft I have a
funny feeling it's gonna rebalance it's
gonna probably drop down I wanted to
make sure I was gonna be able to pull
out my initial investment with a little
bit of a profit because it's not
necessarily when I look at it as like oh
this is gonna be long term just going up
like crazy so I still have a little bit
in the game but if I lose it all or if
it goes back down to five I'm still
covered mm-hmm so a great way I like to
get to know people as moral dilemmas so
I'm gonna ask you a question and I want
to see what your answers gonna be okay
so say you're on a bridge and there's a
train going underneath the bridge
there's five people on the tracks of the
Train underneath you there's a person
leaning over the edge of the bridge you
can push this person off of the bridge
in front of the train and the train will
stop and not hit the five people or you
can just let whatever happened happened
why can't you just yell at the people to
have them get off the track they can't
hear you they can't hear you would why
you're mute you're like the hot most
hardcore mime that's ever existed sure
the choice is a person but you're in a
dip let's assume you're in a different
room you press a button the one person
in the bridge or you don't press the
button and the five people bye-bye more
about the individual people because if
one was like a convicted like if one has
done all these heinous crime don't know
you don't know that's the thing you just
don't know yep five seconds to make the
decision what would you do five or they
both go or they or they both yeah if you
don't change this everyone's going I
guess then you go with the one person
but it's hard to say sacrifice a life at
the at the cost of the greater good to
that there's nothing I do struggle with
but I don't know okay let's say that the
five people on that so I think it's a
different question when you say they're
just like roaming on the tracks because
then they're practicing that safe behave
that's what I was thinking yes you push
the person then that person's being
completely safe by leaning over the edge
like reasonably safe you know in the
other people but what if they're tied
the time so it's like what are they
doing are they is it are you talking
about five people and they five children
on their cuz I mean I'd imagine a four
year old child it's not gonna know to
get out of the way it's a very dismal
yeah let us know down in the defense's
the more I thought about that the more
I'm thinking like well they're on their
tracks it would be you know tied but
okay so if their time well yeah I mean
if they're tied against their will I'd
probably though I'd get rid of the one
person to save the fine
that person's innocent the only person
who walks out of that situation on NSA
is yourself unless you're the one to
cause one person either way you're what
like the media would say in a situation
like that like hero sacrifice someone
else let's do that though cars will
always like like the Tesla's on
autopilot we'll try to look to do what
whatever's gonna be the least amount of
damage that's small right know that oh
yeah I don't know would you do Graham if
I had ten seconds and no information I'd
probably let the person on the bridge
live so I'm basically just gonna ask you
a few questions so everyone can get to
know you what is something that really
gets you angry I I would probably say
that would be bad drivers I do a lot of
commuting and so I just see this all the
time but the amount of people that are
on their phone or that will cut in so
close to you there's so many times even
on the way home be driving home today I
almost got hit twice by somebody who
just was not looking and almost hit took
off the whole engine part of my car
because they just decided to lane change
so I say just people that drive I see
people drive halfway in between other
lanes I'm just swerve over back run
lights like just crazy stuff all the
time and it makes me so angry or
especially when somebody's just like
sitting there on their phone with and
they're going at least 60 miles per hour
right because it's the freeway that is
so dangerous you're not sitting at a
stoplight your car isn't stopped you are
going at a speed where if you crash it
is going to be dangerous and you could
hurt someone else it makes me so mad
mhm aside from necessities what's one
thing that you could not go a day
without Ramsey Ramsey I can't compete
with Ramsey yeah well no you're in
necessity no but not like rant Ramsey's
oh I get I get really sad when I'm not
home for a few days and they don't get
to see our cat she doesn't even ask for
pictures of me she's like can you send
me a picture
Ramsey she yeah she's done that before
Wow I'm like he's here yeah he doesn't
change like just here's an old picture I
don't know no I've never said I've never
seen you know there's one time he texted
me and I forget where he was it's just
an old picture of Ramsey but I know I
didn't
on a typical Saturday night would you
rather stay in or go out stay in stay in
he likes dinging grandmum I'm guessing
your day you're the same I would say
eight times out of ten stay
and I would say something like two maybe
two to three nights out of ten I'd
rather go out or do something but I like
being in bed early so like I would love
to go out but then know that like okay
tell me am I gonna be home so what time
would you go out I would say the best
times to go out honestly between 6:00
and 10:00
mm-hmm that's it 6:00 and 10:00 perfect
time to go out and in you're home early
that that's when I would go out what
about you
I would probably most of the time I
probably rather stand
I love being social and I love being
around friends but preferably like
they'd be coming to me and he just hang
out at my place I don't like going out
and going to parties very much there's
just too many people and ya know are you
the type of person who would like to
plan out an agenda for a vacation or
would you rather kind of just go with
the flow for vacations I'm very just I
want to go with the flow I want to have
my brain off I would like to kind of
generally know before like hey are we
gonna be possibly doing this I can plan
the right outfits I can't just show up
with the jeans so like everywhere in
Vegas no of course I can't wear my mom
jeans into like beauty and SX per se
it's not a lot but generally I kind of
like to know what we're about gonna be
doing on that trip but on the trip I
just want to shut my brain off and just
go with the flow
but on a day-to-day I'm so much more
scheduled like everything has to be done
this has to stop at this I think this
has to start like very very scheduled
but I like when I go on vacations just
to turn my brain off mm-hmm and Gramps
always go with the flow I always about
to say a plan everything really grand
would be a planner yeah oh yeah I hate
surprises now I want to know yeah that's
why you don't like options trading nope
no surprise there would you rather be an
ugly genius or a hot [ __ ] Oh ugly
genius for sure Graham I feel really
smart people who run
society smart ugly people run society
well I'm not saying necessarily ugly you
can try not me but I'm very very smart
are the ones who run like you look at
some of these football guys right and
they're getting you know they're getting
five million six million for like a
season or whatever there's a guy who
owns that if you're smart you're not
gonna try to you're not gonna try to be
a player you're gonna try to go above
that to be the guy who can afford to pay
people six million to be on your team
well I guess yeah yeah if you're if
you're smart you may see all these
actors and we just want a monetary like
reasons but just like what if you were
just you had no money in either way so
like money is taken out of ways like
your you make eighty thousand a year no
matter what yeah so smart so smart oh my
goodness no I couldn't stand it be just
dumb to the point where I would know but
you wouldn't know you're dumb yeah if
you're dumb you probably wouldn't know
you're dumb like this money you tell me
something the smarter you get the more
you realize you don't you got to slow
down your words oh sorry
you won't understand you small words no
big tiny words talking like Kevin Malone
here well that's good
both options so the last question would
you the last question would you rather
be itchy or sticky for the rest of your
life miserable
I'd have to I'd have to do sticky even
though I'd hate it worse because I have
been so itchy that I have broken open
skin by scratching oh that is that is
this is a real story and there's like
this big of a scar on my leg
from me touching grass because I'm
allergic to grass and me itchy it with
one of my feet and not paying attention
would like go back on my feet and I
broke open skin and I still have like
this because
are down my leg for that so I would have
to do sticky because I've never injured
myself being sticky
yeah I'd say sticky is just like
mosquito bites and stuff like like it's
just I hate itching something and then
continue because this crazy teas itchy
all the way like being sticky is one of
the grossest things if my fingers are
sticky and I'm like count me out count
me yeah it makes you itchy just thinking
about being itchy being itchy is kind of
nice sometimes like if you get a good
mosquito by now on your leg
it doesn't go away that makes it worse
to itch it and then you're up late it's
not a euphoric sensation yes does it go
away it just doesn't go away you do it
right no but if in this case well then
it then you wouldn't be sticky if you're
able to just nope rub it away like then
so in that lot of you would just you
would continually be itchy I think that
there is at least some benefit to always
being itchy however there's no benefit
to always being sticky what do you what
do you guys think about this right this
reminds me it's like like pain and
pleasure back in high school for all of
junior and senior year I would wake up
at 4:00 a.m. in the morning to a
horrible song and I would wake up and I
would turn the alarm off and then go
back to sleep and then wake up at 7:00
because I loved the sensation of going
back to sleep after la be screwed up
your entire schedule by doing that
really yeah but I would do I just like
knock right back out I'm so tired
yeah roll off your REM sleep this is
gonna be a thing we're from but whenever
I didn't finish homework or I had just
homework sitting there that I could have
done I used to in high school wake up at
like 3:00 a.m. and do it for an hour and
then go back to sleep that's odd
I the best part too would be the next
day I wouldn't remember any of it it
would be totally Cokie like good
homework it was fine mm-hmm it was like
there we go now I don't have to waste
any conscious time doing homework it's
weird that's really weird yeah yeah oh
that's weird
yeah not listening up waking up they're
both weird so you have to wake up at
7:00 you wake up at 6:00 and then you
like oh I have an extra hour of sleep is
that not like an amazing feeling not
really to me cuz sometimes I'll end up
going back to bed and then I'm even more
tired it's just usually better for me
just to wake up hmm yeah yeah if I wake
up that late I'm just staying awake
anytime past five am i I'm awake for the
rest of the day
mm-hmm so mm-hmm but you're also the
same person that likes to have
nightmares psychopath let's let's let's
talk about niño okay let's totally
change this table let's talk about niño
because the thing with niño is you know
how I like I sold out at like 750 and
because I just didn't like having it you
know it's it's skyrocketed afterwards of
course and I just couldn't stand seeing
the stock go up every single day knowing
that that was more money than FOMO
right no FOMO you should never have FOMO
but I was totally getting it and I hated
seeing go up every single day so when it
was at like twelve forty yesterday I
bought it okay so is that 1240 and I
bought a hundred shares okay and then
immediately I did a limit order I didn't
do a market order I did a limit order
but immediately after I bought it it
just plummeted and I lost like 50 bucks
I was so old you sell I
I'm getting there I was so over and I oh
and I was like I this is not for me it
went back up to like 1242 okay because I
held so now I was like two cents in the
green per share and then I put a stop
loss at 12:40 which is where you know I
would have broke even you started going
up started going up and then I put
a limit at 1275 and it hit it and I made
$35 well how long did that take
seven minutes oh this is worth of stuff
going on no actually I think it was he
was 10 minutes it took 10 minutes
exactly yeah so 10 minutes that's name
thing is going to the casino that's all
you're doing it's not because how can I
consistently put up these numbers how
can I consistently get the money could
you that at a casino that's true hey I'm
two for two
alright keep keep doing it then I also
sold another put okay for TNA and it
went down and how it's losing a lot of
money yeah but now it's back up and I'm
up ten cool it's gonna happen it's gonna
go down in value you're gonna lose money
and then Monday it's gonna open like 30%
higher that's what's gonna happen it's
good it's it's doing the thing that
scammers do we're like it gives you a
little bit oh and then I go big yeah
scamming 101 exactly yeah so we'll see
what happens if niño is lower than 24 95
on Friday then I lost money so don't
know that very yeah so you're expecting
in two days for it to go up $10 sure
oh my gosh did I say ni oh I'm so sorry
I'm a temp okay you guys get the point
yeah so yeah that's that's the whole
status with that I'm good good luck you
know what in the beginning is a video we
should go over how much the podcast
makes and then how much you have made or
lost its he's becoming a Graham
grandpa my memory is not what it used to
be all right we'll do that
okay right now I'm up you know what it
would be funny it's like here's your
brain and then here's your brain on the
YouTube algorithm I just see how that
makes you crazy it does this is your
brain this is your brain on $0.20 iced
coffee oh oh it's you know the meme
where it stirs like the brain it's like
yeah yeah that's what it should be
that's funny who's got to make a meme of
that so yeah I'm up 50 dollars so far
and then the TNA will put me up another
55 works cool so shabby cool
let's see also have you guys heard of
dogecoin wait that's an actual thing I
thought that was a meme somebody
commented on my Instagram are they DMV
and I was like haha because I thought it
was a I thought it was a joke no it's a
real thing you know what I hate to sigh
wait which one is this where there's one
that there's one crypto where the guy
was like I have no idea this doesn't
have any value I have no idea why you
guys are trading it it's probably
dogecoin yeah but I think it's that one
do you know that like the Doge meme I'll
throw it up for you guys to see it
but the Doge meme with like the the I
don't know what it is like a lab or
something like yeah or something yeah
they made like a crypto out of it and
like this one guy I saw it made a tick
talked about it yesterday and the tick
tock went viral and since it was such as
a low volume he was telling everyone buy
it
cuz if you put in like $25 right now if
it goes up to one doll you made like 25
grand or something like oh that's yeah
yeah I'm pretty sure that's the crypto
that I was thinking about where they got
tweeted like there's there's no value of
this Elon Musk tweeted about it when
this was early April I think I thought
this was a meme no no so I put in $300
today and at one point I was up 20% and
now you guys are gonna get some live
let's see here let's see exactly what's
going on with dogecoin
I'm up eight dollars and ten cents yes
so 20% yeah so a cup $60 but a cool
eight dollars and ten cents for a
dogecoin well and volumes going up all
the night I hate to say it but usually
what ends up happening is that people DM
me with those things and I've seen it a
few times like in my calm and say it
leave people like polka and dot
you know dogecoin or whatever I never do
it and it does end up usually going up
and then it crashes hard within like a
week two weeks but I don't know I had a
pretty decent entry point how do you buy
it where do you buy it on Robin Hood put
ten dollars in all right all right
Graham's gonna put in $10 in dogecoin
let's see transfers how do you transfer
to Robin Hood does it show the next
transfer don't you have like $10 no no I
can I'm gonna go big man really I'll
just you have to wait until I test it
Robin Hood gold wait wait well your
money's on this way will give you early
access to a thousand dollars in your
buying power so you can invest it right
away
Graham is doing dogecoin on Robin Hood
Mart margin trading that's awesome
this is so stupid Oh guys I'm just don't
invest anything all transparency here
but honestly this is like straight-up
got back from Vegas this is just a
gamble let's see oh my god I give it two
hundred sixteen thousand Doge Graham has
two hundred and sixteen thousand
dogecoins I have to review my Robin this
might make this might be enough to make
the stock go up so for that I thank you
I've never seen Graham spend this much
money invest your shows I show that show
the camera
this is dogecoin that's it's a gamble
I'm making it very clear I don't believe
did it alright well let's see what
happens
grams position is at point zero zero
four six so you guys can keep track
cheese mine is at point zero zero four
five zero two is what I would I have
dogecoin at okay so we'll see we'll yeah
it's it's good it's going down man so
we'll watch alright wait keep an eye on
it it's investing okay gosh it was a
gamble making it very clear for everyone
who's watching this right now don't put
anything into dogecoin that you cannot
afford to lose remember that so oh but
definitely do it so easy on Robin Hood
honestly it really is they have
everything on Bitcoin yeah etherium
that's the one thing with weeble I wish
they had crypto mm-hmm not for me and
I'm just saying hey like everything on
Robin Hood looks really nice here like
the format app like yeah you know what
you should tell them that they can get
their two free stocks down below in the
description they deposit $100 on weibo
mm-hmm I think they'll be doing
cryptocurrency at some point I think
that's the point Bible
Robin oh they're only does one free
stock we build is to free stones with
that second stock valued all the way up
to $1400 Wow
you guys should be doing weeble because
if you do do Robin Hood you're just
gonna lose money yeah
cryptocurrency do have you what are your
experiences with crypto because people
want to know mine
yeah you too amazing man so I was aware
of it our friend Artie believe it or not
2011 was telling me about Bitcoin and I
remember he was showing me like one of
these websites where he could buy like
crap from with with Bitcoin and I think
at the time one Bitcoin was a dollar and
I remember talking to him and being like
I don't get it so it's it's it's equal
to a dollar it's like no no this is the
value of it right now I'm so it I didn't
get it I didn't like it and I thought it
was like this little you know this thing
I saw always paid attention to it but I
just thought it was silly I don't see I
just thought it was kind of you never
think
I did mm late 2017 right is the coin was
going up well that was the peak of
everything of crypto I bought in I think
I bought in like 15 grand or like 17
grand or something like that and I dated
Bitcoin I remember and I would just like
Buy in and I was so much fun it was
really it was just gambling that's all
it was mines be a lot of what people are
doing with stocks now and Robin Hood
it's just kind of like buying in and out
day trading it and uh I think I made
like a little money doing that and then
I decided like and this is this is
stupid
so I put it in litecoin I made a little
money in like coin but then I put it in
ryback's and oh man and that was back
when it was like $2 and then it went all
the way to 40 something dollars and I
didn't sell it and now it's so what was
the value of your portfolio your oh man
I only I only invested like I think I'd
like 5 grand or something in riah blocks
I spread it out throughout a whole
bundle way from 2 to 40 with 5 grand
yeah so I don't know what the profit was
something like that it was it was so it
was something like that and I didn't
sell it so stupid I always was $44 on
New Year's Eve
and I remember being like okay it's
gonna be listed and next week I'm one of
these major exchanges and then once it
hits that exchange it's gonna double
from there that's a stupid own any of it
yeah
still to this day holding all of it yeah
what's it worth like a dollar dollar
each sir I lost half my money in that
and what if it's a dollar each it went
from 40 to a dollar so you can't win
them all
no that was that was a stupid less I was
just being greedy mm-hmm yeah and also I
didn't have enough money in there to
throw like my initial investment was low
enough rifle it goes down at least I
have my year so stupid
whatever and what about what about you
crypto I feel like there's nothing
backing it I can look with
knees and look at their financials look
at there's so much I can look at with
the company when I choose to invest with
them I feel like repetitious gambling so
I've been touched it it really nice
watch close friends of ours make a lotta
money and then lose about the same
amount and then just completely break
even and I knew I could do better with
it on the stock market with having more
information yeah that's that's fair yeah
that's fair
I'm not a huge fan of crypto IRA either
so except dogecoin check out the red why
do you believe in Doge going to be
besides it just going up and have you
seen the Doge no she showed you the Doge
yeah yeah the mean how could you not
believe in that look at that face and
tell that face you don't believe this
that's so stupid let's just see if I've
made money now no rap I'm down two
percent I'm down this is the first time
I'm down I think today why doesn't it go
up why don't you sue them as soon as I
bought it it went down dude
so easily if you if you check out the
Doge reddit it's backed people have
theirs there's good at most yeah I'm
buying into this hype like massively
Mase look at this like that's what I
just bought into it's like this is huge
I texted you earlier today check out
dogecoin and if you bought in when I
texted you you would've been up 20
percent at one point now down about half
a percent is your is your phone back run
a hotdog you took a bite out of I didn't
take a bite out of it now yeah I did I
just
double hot dog ah all right well what's
she double hot dog okay it's good so I'm
down like 20 $20 20 yeah this is
investing in your future all right okay
fair enough
this is investing for your children okay
this is what this becomes like only
major like the next big crypto current
like it replaces the dollar thousand
shares two hundred and seventeen
thousand people are laughing now but
where will they be when you're a
dogecoin millionaire millionaire he's a
real estate I need to be eggs dogecoin
now you got to be millionaires and other
things other currencies your Youtube
million and a real estate millionaire
yeah but you got to be a currency
millionaire like me you got to be a
millionaire every single currency this
is Bob way I would be this in Bob wait a
trillionaire that's true yeah no more
than that what's what's above a trillion
quadrillion trillion quintillion there
quintillion they're still Ian septal
yeah Becca Tilian I don't know that
sounds like reptiles at this point all
right all right well check out Doge
going guys okay it can only go up that's
what I heard possibly goes up
what other questions you have all right
I mean we have this stuff where DMing
celebrities I picked up ten if you'd
like to do that oh wow do you want to do
that so we can yeah Kenan and Kel by the
way never got back to me neither one of
them did yeah all right who who am I
gonna do okay so I have a list of ten
people people were saying that you
should do the the most likely one was
actually Gus Johnson I think oh I love
him Johnson what should I say how about
lunch on me anytime you're in LA
how's that yes but that McDonald's okay
who else okay we also have Trevor
Wallace and Charlie's oh I like that
he's the one who did the funny
entreprenuer video yeah I actually met
Trevor Wallace I'll throw up a really
cool picture of me and him right now for
you guys Z you should you should say hey
man saw your entrepreneur video I would
love to that's that's great that's a
great angle I would love if you ever
want to parody that with me I would love
to do that that's a good one
yeah we also have Dave Ramsey oh hey man
my cats named after you
h3h3 Oh Ethan Klein yeah cuz I mean I'm
a I'm a huge fan of ethan klein as well
he actually went to my rival high school
which is kind of odd so he grew up in
the same city and he went to our rival
high school okay someone wanted you to
DM the undertaker what's that he's the
rest yeah I see it what should I say one
of these days you want a wrestle yeah
should I know you maybe that would be
good so like this video if you guys want
to see Graham wrestle the Undertaker
million likes and he'll do it just say
lunch just big you know he's popular you
could take him to lunch I would take him
to lunch probably eat half the
restaurant
if you're ever in all I would love to
take you to lunch all right done okay
and finally Adam 22 so I think he runs a
podcast yeah oh oh yeah he's um what you
McCall I've seen no jumper or no sir
yeah yeah so as Graham is DMing the
final celebrity we are going to let you
know next podcast that none of them
damned us back you and I Ramsey we dance
seven celebrities so one of them has to
get back right I would say we're gonna
get two responses Trevor I think would
respond back and I think Gus I would
respond h3 responds yeah I don't I think
Ethan is too big but I think Trevor and
Gus
mm-hm that's my guess all right
everybody will see and if you guys like
this kind of content let us know if you
want to see gram DM more celebrities you
know that's I mean that's what we got I
mean we do have the classic question
that you actually never got asked but
would you rather fight one you know I
know the question you know okay so ever
since I found that I was gonna be on
this podcast to do a lot of thinking do
I get a weapon absolutely not no okay is
mayonnaise a weapon I think it could be
interesting if I did one horse-sized
duck but I think logically I should
choose the hundred duck-sized horses and
if you chose those how many could you
take I don't know I feel like just some
of those with their size you just have
to kick them but I'd feel so bad to do
that they're a rabid they're not nice
rabid is in like they're going after
Ramsay
oh shoot ya know I protect him with my
life
just like holder and run away he sneeze
did you hear the love cat sees it she
doesn't know what to do oh if you wanted
to do I do that 100 sized dogs and I
think you could probably take a hundred
a hundred okay yeah I think I could do
the task I don't think I could go any
more over that I think I would get
really tired kicking things away mhm
yeah is there anything you'd like to
discuss on the podcast doing your own
channel I think there's a possibility
I'm not thinking about it right now
though I just don't think that I have
the time in my schedule to do that and
then when are you dropping out of
college not gonna have that should be
the last question in every podcast so
when you drop out of college now you
know like you want to do it later
thanks again road for hooking us up with
these mics they're awesome
for anyone who's thinking about getting
a mic wants to know like what's the best
for audio this is amazing like
absolutely some of the best mics ever
like you're not even gonna hear ramsey
going away they might hear ramsey going
it's so loud yeah he wants a treat right
now cuz he has food he has everything he
needs all right so with that said you
guys thank you so much for watching
don't forget to smash the YouTube button
really appreciate it
make sure to add us on Instagram you
poster pretty much daily so if you want
to be a part of it there if you would
add us there and lastly stories stories
sorry um okay so anyway get your two
free stocks down below in the
description weeble is gonna be giving
you 2 free stocks we don't wait when you
depress 100 on the platform with one of
the stocks valued all the way up to 1000
for $2 let's just check really quick
Robin Hood if I made money I know you're
down all that crap okay I don't -
alright alright with that said you guys
thank you so much for watching and is
the last time
we take it home now oh yeah I think it's
gonna be the title is gonna be like our
riskiest investment ever